les premiers sextuplé français leur
maman vont aussi bien que possible ce
soir un document sur les problèmes posés
par ces naissances multiples sur le plan
matériel et de l'éducation avec une
famille danger qui depuis sept ans et
demi élève cinq enfants arménie un
convoi d'une association humanitaire
française attaqués par des pillards le
responsable du convoi témoigne de la
pagaille et du désespoir qui règne dans
les régions sinistrées à nîmes 18
municipalités ont signé une charte pour
que la ville s'adapte aux handicapés
enquête dans ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir 38 jours très
exactement après le tremblement de terre
en arménie un convoi d'une association
humanitaire française amitié pologne qui
était parti en signe de solidarité
livrer du matériel et les vêtements sur
place dans les zones sinistrées a été
attaqués par des pillards
cet incident qui remonte à 48 heures à
peine témoigne de l'état de pagaille
d'insécurité et de désespoir également
qui règne actuellement dans les régions
sinistrées
les habitants livrés à eux mêmes se
plaignent de ne pas bénéficier de la
distribution des secours internationaux
qui s'entassent pourtant dans la
capitale erevan avec les risques de
corruption et de détournements que l'on
peut imaginer
le président de cette association
humanitaire alain michel qui dirigeait
ce convoi est rentré aujourd'hui même
avec un document qui à lui seul suffit à
dresser un constat de la situation en
arménie aujourd'hui delphine de la scène
les autres pohdh erevan sont bondés et
les colis ne cessent d'arriver
entreposés en vrac la plupart ne
pourront pas être triés avant la
distribution
alain michel et son équipe comptent
acheminer plus de 40 tonnes de
marchandises vers les villages très de
spitak sur place
l'anarchie et la violence la
distribution de vivres de vêtements et
de médicaments est devenu un véritable
tour de force parfois dangereux des
chaînes d'autant plus que quand on leur
donne la marchandise qui arrivent comme
celle qu'on distribuait non pas celle
qu'on avait apporté mais celle qu'on
nous avait demandé de distribuer c'était
des cartons dans laquelle il y avait des
maillots de bain
des cartons dans laquelle il y avait 500
paires de tongs avait des chemisettes et
500 chemisette à une mère de famille
c'est un gros problème
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'elle fasse
de 500 chemise est pour mais les
contrebandiers ou les
les mafiosi du coin eux savent très bien
ce qu'ils vont en faire des blue-jeans
qui vont recevoir et c'est donc ensuite
ils vont attaquer la marchandise y ont
attaqué les autres villages ils ont
racketté des villages et ils vont
racketter aussi les gens qui apportent
la marchandise
hier matin à la fin de la distribution
du dernier village on avait encore la
marchandise pour d'autres villages
mais on a été poursuivis par des
voitures qui déjà toute la journée où on
monter la tension en essayant de
récupérer de la marchandise de volée de
la marchandise qui nous ont suivis
c'était donc en pleine nuit et ont
accompagné le camion sur plus de 20
kilomètres on a dû forcer deux fois les
barrages de voiture la troisième fois la
voiture était carrément en face on est
obligé de s'arrêter ou de l'écraser ce
n'était pas possible
et là on s'est trouvé confronté aux
pilleurs on sait qu'ils sont des
villageois qui sont les gens de la ville
de spitak d'elena cannes etc qui ont des
voitures qui sont organisés en mafia
pour piller les camions c'est ce qui
s'est passé ils sont sortis ils étaient
assez nombreux et avec couteaux haches
et caetera et on a eu un affrontement à
la limite de la de l'extrême violence
ils ont commencé à ouvrir les camions
pendant ce temps notre camionnette
d'assistance a pu rejoindre un poste de
militaires soviétiques qui sont venus à
la rescousse avec les armes et caetera
et après des affrontements où il ya
quand même eu des échanges de de feu
mais aussi d'armes blanches
on a pu repartir après pour aider
l'arménie aujourd'hui il faut dans un
premier temps cesser les expéditions de
marchandises pour permettre d'acheminer
ce qui est déjà sur place et dans un
deuxième temps reprendre ses emplois
mais cette fois mieux préparés et
peut-être plus adapté
sur le plan politique moscou a décidé
aujourd'hui de reprendre directement en
main sous son contrôle provisoirement du
moins le gouvernement de la province du
karabakh en azerbaïdjan où ces derniers
mois souvenez-vous arménien et
populations locales azéri se sont
affrontés presse violemment voilà ce que
l'on pouvait lire sur ce dossier ce soit
retour en france 48 heures après
l'accident de téléphérique devosge à
nice dans les alpes près de l'alpe
d'huez la commission d' enquête poursuit
ses investigations
la dernière hypothèse en date un
déverrouillage de la télécabine dans
laquelle se trouvaient les huit
techniciens qui sont morts jacques
violer les experts des deux commissions
d'enquêté
une administrative l'autre judiciaire
sont au travail défaillance technique ou
erreur humaine
ils sont chargés d'établir les
responsabilités les deux pièces
principales du système et qui semble en
cause sont ces taxes au milieu des
débris et le chariot rester sur les
câbles lax maintient la cabine au
chariot qui glisse sur les câbles il
doit pivoter dans son fourreau pour que
la cabine soit toujours verticale
pendant les trajets
cette pièce par est intact mais son
extrémité fichiers dans le sol il faut
donc pouvoir l'examiner
d'autre part le chariot toujours sur les
câbles mais qui a basculé
il a quitté le câble porteur où il doit
être mais il est resté sur le câble
tracteur après avoir chaviré ce chariot
doit être ramené à la station en l'état
une opération délicate soit l' axe est
sorti de son logement
parce qu'il n'a pas été bloquée
verrouillé à l'intérieur il y aurait
alors erreur humaine
s'il y avait au contraire rupture de
pièces métalliques il y aurait
défaillance technique
mais ce soir toutes les hypothèses sont
prématurées il faudra plusieurs jours
pour examiner ces pièces
les sextuplés de la maternité de port
royal à paris se porte aussi bien que
possible quatre d'entre eux sont en
couveuse et deux autres placés sous
respiration artificielle
quant à la maman marie claude adam elle
est fatiguée on peut comprendre hier
soir nous faisions l'écho des problèmes
d'éthique médicale que ces possibilités
de traitement contre la stérilité posait
dans la mesure où ils ont souvent pour
conséquence des naissances multiples au
delà parfois désespérant ce départ ce
soir sur un plan plus pratique et et
familiale nos envoyés spéciaux alain
labouze et christian leroux se sont
rendus à angers où ils ont rencontré une
famille qui il ya sept ans et demi
maintenant a eu des quintuplés cette
famille a eu la bonne idée de filmer
régulièrement l'évolution de leurs
enfants ses parents donne également
quelques conseils qui seront fort utiles
à marie-claude lorsqu'elle sera rentrée
chez elle pour les cwatupe l'est de
saint barthélemy d'anjou
tout a commencé le 21 juillet 1981 après
deux premiers enfants madame labbé a dû
prendre un traitement pour stimuler ses
ovaires
résultat cinq bébés trois filles et deux
garçons d'un kilo 3,1 kg 6 au début
c'était la crèche 24 heures sur 24 à la
maison combien de biberons par jean 40
biberons par jour nuit et jour les ponts
et puis les petits coquins ne vais pas
toujours la même heure alors ça
s'échelonner toute la journée toute la
nuit
pour les promener on avait des landes
autres jumeaux et alain de simple il
fallait donc 3 pour pousser les gens
d'où est autrement pour l'échangé on
avait deux coussins de change pour aller
deux fois plus vite mais par contre on a
toujours on leur a toujours donné le
biberon
individuellement les a jamais calé sur
des coussins ou on a toujours privilégié
l'instant qu'on pouvait avoir avec
chaque chacun d'eux de façon à ce qu'ils
aient chacun leur moment avec nous et
qu'on se régale un peu avec chacun deux
fois parce qu'il faut pas non plus que
c'est pour nous faut passer l'impression
que ce soit l'usiné
même si c'était un peu ça maintenant
sept ans et demi chacun des enfants à sa
place bien à lui
on se trompe parfois de chaussures mais
question organisation dans la famille
labbé on reste imbattable
les garçons de carreaux et non pendant
enfin à mon collègue richard conte tarn
puis quand la laine shop
comment ça se passe quand tu prends ma
voiture quand vous prenez votre temps
les garçons jouent derrière musulmans et
sa maman sont quand vous prenez le bain
vous êtes tous ensemble ou bien c'est
chacun son tour
ces pertes sont au tapis
et toi plus tard tu voudras avoir
beaucoup d'enfants
combien
ao 4 quand tu seras grand tu feras quoi
ce film il est 7h15 et animaux dans un
zoo pour quoi faire
si vous aviez des conseils à donner aux
parents à dans la qui viennent d'avoir
des sextuplés qu'ils choisissent bien
leurs parrains et marraines pour leurs
enfants parce que les entreprises ont
besoin de références personnelles qu'ils
puissent passer des week-ends une fois
de temps en temps tout seul qui se
reposaient que des amis passent des
nuits organise des nuits des nuits de
garde
c'est très important pouvoir se coucher
le soir en se disant c'est n'y aura pas
être réveillé pour donner à vivre on
s'est pressé à fond c'est agréable
oui on le comprend si vous avez vous
même si vous attendez vous même
plusieurs enfants ou si vous avez
plusieurs enfants voici l'adresse peut
être utile d'une association qui pourra
vous conseiller dans tous les domaines
éducation et matérielles
un avion militaire français transportant
des gendarmes mobiles bloqué sur la
piste de l'aéroport de saint pierre et
miquelon départements français aux
portes du canada cette manifestation de
mauvaise humeur est en rapport avec les
problèmes de quotas de pêche activité
essentielle de l'île jérôme bellay des
premières images
un transall amenant des gardes mobiles
de la métropole bloqué sur l'aéroport de
saint pierre et miquelon et l'autre
obligé de se dérouter vers saint jean
les pêcheurs de l'archipel veut ainsi
manifester leur colère face à ces forces
de l'ordre envoyés en prévision de
l'arrivée demain du nouveau préfet à
l'origine de la grogne des pêcheurs
l'échec des négociations avec le
gouvernement français sur la répartition
des quotas de pêche entre pêcheurs de
l'archipel et pêcheurs metropolit
malgré la décision du ministère de la
mer de limiter les captures de
l'armement métropolitain à 3000 tonnes
de morue pour le premier semestre
les pêcheurs ont décidé de maintenir
demain une opération ville morte et leur
colère est attisée par l'arrivée prévue
dans leurs eaux d'un second chalutier
industriel de saint malo
le sénateur maire de saint pierre et
miquelon albert peine apparenté
socialiste
ne nage pas scellé albert peine vient
d'annoncer qu'il avait décidé de prendre
ses distances vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste et on apprend que le transall
a finalement décollé de l'aéroport de
saint pierre et miquelon une information
encore quelque peu mystérieuse en
belgique l'ancien premier ministre paul
vanden boeynants ce pourrait avoir été
enlevée il a disparu en effet de son
domicile bruxellois depuis hier soir
samedi soir un interlocuteur anonyme se
réclamant de la brigade socialistes
révolutionnaires a revendiqué son
enlèvement dans un coup de téléphone à
la radio télévision belge monsieur
vandenbon ans qui avait été deux fois
premier ministre venait d'être récemment
condamné à trois ans de prison avec
sursis pour fraude fiscale et il était
sous le coup d'un nouveau procès a
accusé d'avoir à l'époque où il était
ministre de la défense cette fois l'a
fait vendre de la viande à l'armée belge
par l'intermédiaire d'une société qui
lui appartenait à grenoble encore en
bref un petit garçon de 11 ans vient
d'être retrouvé ce soir par des
promeneurs mort étranglé il avait quitté
son domicile vendredi après midi pour se
rendre police la politique étrangère
maintenant la politique d'ouverture
prônée par l'union soviétique pour elle
même et l'ensemble des pays de l'est
prise en défaut aujourd'hui à prague en
tchécoslovaquie où 2000 personnes
voulaient commémorer le suicide par le
feu de jan palach c'était étudiants qui
souvenez vous le 16 janvier 69 s'est
immolé par le feu pour protester contre
l'écrasement par la force du printemps
de prague
vingt ans après la police a violemment
chargé 93 arrestations et des blessés
michel mompontet il voulait juste se
souvenir vingt ans après mais pour
certains ici en tchécoslovaquie
il y a des souvenirs intolérable
interdiction formelle de toute
manifestation
et pourtant ils étaient plus de 2 me
avoir décidé de participer quand même au
rassemblement de cette place wenceslas
ils ont tout juste eu le temps de crier
jan polak
nous ne t'oublierons pas les unités
anti-émeutes qui quadrillait en force
depuis le matin même le quartier ont
chargé gaz lacrymogènes matraques et
canons à eau
arrestations plusieurs blessés graves
un scénario écrit comme al avance par
les autorités de chèques ici même sur
cette place il ya 20 ans s'immoler par
le feu jan palach un jeune étudiant
tchèque n'ayant pu se résoudre à voir
mourir le rêve de démocratie qu'il a
vécu pour son pays lors d'un certain
printemps 68 à prague
dans ce cortège funèbre le 19 janvier
tout prague est là mais depuis la tombe
de jan palach a été discrètement
déplacées par les autorités loin de la
capitale comme vous pour effacer encore
se souvenir
jan polak était bien parmi ces jeunes
pragoise ce matin du 22 août 1968 à
pleurer au passage des tanks soviétiques
durant six mois il avait cru comme on
croit 20 ans en un monde meilleur plus
juste plus libre pour son pays jusqu'à
ce que cinq cent mille hommes du pacte
de varsovie ne vienne briser ce rêve
vient de ballack n'avait tout simplement
pas voulu survivre
le bilan de la collision ferroviaire
survenu ce matin au bangladesh
s'alourdit d'heure en heure pour
l'instant les sauveteurs ont dénombré 61
morts et 1000 blessés mais ces chiffres
pourraient malheureusement évoluer très
vite dans la mesure où beaucoup de
voyageurs sont encore coincées à
l'intérieur des wagons pascal deschamps
cette femme avait un parent dans le
train elle garde encore l'espoir de ne
pas le trouver parmi les morts en
contrebas de la voie ferrée une rangée
de corps en silence les uns derrière les
autres
des dizaines de villageois défilent pour
identifier un membre de leur famille
disparu dans l'accident
les soldats surveillent pour empêcher
les vivants de piller est mort
combien sont ils à avoir péri dans ces
amas de tôle nul ne peut le dire encore
seules 72 corps ont été dégagés et il y
aurait encore selon les sauveteurs
près de 300 corps prisonniers des wagons
un bilan à la mesure d'un réseau
ferroviaire surchargé avec des trains
bondés et vétuste à l'origine de la
collision sans doute une défaillance du
système de signalisation
une enquête a été ouverte demain a été
décrété jour de deuil national
le magazine américain business week
affirme après enquête que non seulement
l'allemagne fédérale mais douze pays au
moins allant de la grande bretagne en
passant par la suisse l'italie le japon
et la france auraient participé
volontairement ou involontairement à la
construction de ce que le gouvernement
américain affirme être une usine
d'armement chimiques en libye
involontairement pour certaines
entreprises dans la mesure où beaucoup
de matériel aurait été détourné de sa
destination initiale par des relais
organisée par les libyens regain
d'agitation dans les territoires occupés
par israël ce week end officiellement
deux palestiniens ont été tués
mais à propos d'israël reportage de ce
soir concerne la politique intérieure de
ce pays lors des dernières élections
souvenez vous elle est partie religion
progresser et l'on pensé un moment que
la droite allait s'allier à eux pour
gouverner mais depuis l'alliance droite
travail issa a été remise ans
il n'empêche il n'empêche qu'on ne se
rend pas toujours compte en europe et en
france particulièrement de l'importance
du pouvoir des religieux dans la vie
politique mais aussi économique d'israël
en choisissant un exemple qui pourrait
être a priori être anecdotique
notre envoyé spécial martine
laroche-joubert nous prouve combien ce
pouvoir est réel et important novembre
en 88 le mois de la victoire pour les
rabats après leur succès aux élections
espoirs semblent permis rêves brisés net
par l'alliance gauche droite
les religieux des cieux choisissent une
autre cible
nouveaux adversaires des rabats les
danseuses du ventre
elles font un tabac en israël depuis
quelques années surtout chez les juifs
d'origine orientale qui retrouve ici la
mémoire de leur origine
spectacle intolérable pour les rabbins
qui menace de retirer le certificat de
cacherout aux établissements est
exigible un certificat qui assure que la
nourriture et cacher c'est à dire
conforme à la tradition juive colère
chez les artistes
la danseuse du ventre
léa gavish docteur en zoologie
spécialiste du comportement des animaux
professeur à l'université de l'hôpital
de jérusalem elle est bien décidée à ne
pas se laisser marcher sur les pieds par
des rabbins le problème avec le rabbinat
est très simple ils essaient de
contrôler la vie de tout le monde
il pense que nous devons agir selon
leurs propres règles
alors nous avons décidé de prendre un
avocat et d'aller devant la haute cour
nous entamerons une procédure judiciaire
quand ils empêcheront les danseuses du
ventre d'aller dans les hôtels ou
ailleurs et sur les hôtels de jérusalem
le pouvoir des rabbins est immense le
véritable patron c'est lui leurs abayas
comme qui peut retirer à tout moment le
fameux certificat de cacherout demandé
par la clientèle juive
il vérifie que la viande et bien séparé
du lait mais se préoccupe aussi de
moralité la danse du ventre c'est
dégoûtant par rapport à la fois juif
oui vraiment ça n'a rien à voir avec
notre religion ces réunions c'est pour
ça que le rabbinat jérusalem a décidé de
chasser les danseuses du ventre des
hôtels quand on retire le cash route on
perd presque tous notre
tout notre business c'est pour pour nous
très très grave on peut fermer l'hôtel
où s'arrête le pouvoir des rabbins
d'après la loi il ne doit pas s'exercer
sur la danse du ventre mais je refuse
actuellement de lâcher tous les moyens
de pression dont on dispose entre les
danseuses et les rabats la guerre est
dévoilée en quelques télégrammes
maintenant les affaires en france tout
d'abord dans la sphère de l'opéra
bastille les démissions se succèdent
après le départ de daniel barenboim le
chef d'orchestre celui de patrice
chéreau metteur en scène aujourd'hui
pierre boulez qui quitte ses fonctions
artistique tout en restant membre de
l'équipe technique chargée de la
construction de l'opéra bastille pierre
boulez qui estime ne plus être te que
pour être tout à fait rigoureux excusez
moi et pierre bergé président de l'opéra
bastille aurait dû quitter la société
yves saint laurent dont il est également
le président pour se consacrer à plein
temps à l'opéra bastille autre affaire
la société générale monsieur chevènement
ministre de la défense indique sur rtl
s'il s'avère que la méthode du marché
n'est pas la bonne pour dénoyautées la
première banque française privée la
société générale donc il faudra
envisager dit monsieur chevènement de la
re nationaliser rapidement encore un
nouveau candidat à la mairie de
marseille
une cinquième liste conduite par
monsieur bernard mas novelli conseiller
général non inscrits anciens rpr et qui
en 1983 au premier tour des municipales
avait obtenu 6 % des suffrages et puis
la majorité d'une majorité
présidentielle qui n'est pas absolue au
parlement comme vous le savez quand un
nouveau député monsieur camille ogata
est lui très loin de nous dans l'île de
wallis et futuna
il a battu le candidat rpr après la
politique les problèmes de société
en effet bien que des progrès aient des
progrès aient été réalisés depuis
quelques années la place et les droits
des handicapés dans nos villes sont loin
d'être respectée aujourd'hui à nîmes 18
municipalités de france et d'europe ont
signé une charte qui les engage à mieux
respecter ses droits mais les handicapés
qui ont voulu ce document estime qu'ils
sont eux aussi qu'ils ont eux aussi des
droits envers la société et des devoirs
également reportage qui ricanent maître
claude dernier
c'est con
attendez et ont traversé
un progrès pour les aveugles mais le
parcours du combattant pour les autres
enfants vieillards accidenté handicapés
pour nous tous un certain moment de
notre vie la rue devient un obstacle
infranchissable
à lannion un maire comme les autres mais
très concernés depuis l'âge de 24 ans
lui il sait les pavés c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite
mais c'est également une difficulté pour
les poussettes pour la mère de famille
qui pousse un landau ces difficultés
aussi que co fois pour les talons hauts
les villes construites au moyen-âge ne
seront pas rasé alors faut-il sur
protéger à tout prix les handicapés
veut horreur qu'on dise que handicapé
est assisté à un handicapé a des droits
mais handicapé à tes devoirs il faut pas
oublier que lorsqu on adapte une ville
pôle handicap et on adapte encore
d'autant mieux pour les personnes
valides
ça on le sait mais d'autre part à un
handicapé doit remplir son rôle
c'est une personne à part entière elle a
des droits civiques et la dea droit
familial avec droits et les devoirs au
niveau professionnel
donc il faut que les handicapés fasse
profiter de leur expérience les
décideurs pouvoirs publics
administrations municipalité les
décideurs possède tonnes gibb la loi de
1975 trop rarement appliquée en
conséquence si tôt dans la rue le
moindre achat banal oblige à réclamer de
l'aide
3,5 millions de personnes sont dans ce
cas les solutions existent de bon sens
il suffit d'y penser de prévoir
le rôle de l'architecte urbaniste se
précise mais s'il veut respecter la loi
il doit affronter les promoteurs et les
maîtres d ouvrage on a des réticences
alors le prétexte c'est le prix le coup
le prétexte sais c'est pas dans le
programme
le prétexte est de quoi vous occuper ces
fêtes le architectes et non je crois que
notre rôle au niveau des programmes est
très important jean-claude périer
participe à l'élaboration de la charte
ville handicap décidé par la ville de
nîmes architectes d'élus handicapés
veulent sensibiliser les maires les
aider à comprendre à trouver des
solutions
une charte difficile à faire respecter
une charte repose sur la volonté
politique
dès lors c'est en fonction de cette
volonté qu'elle sera appliquée que ne
sera pas appliquée beaucoup d'élus
n'attendent pas les quartiers neufs sont
plus facile à aménager l'état distribue
environ 4 milliards par an d'être
financières aux collectivités locales et
aux particuliers mais certains hommes
politiques certaines professions comme
les promoteurs immobiliers souhaitent
des règlements
l'accessibilité à tous nécessitent de
plus grandes surfaces constructibles et
le mètre carré coûte cher pour eux il
faudrait moins de contraintes légales
c'est à la mode tout le monde de
déréglementer notre idée c'est non pas
de déréglementer c'est peut-être de la
rendre plus efficace et plus souple au
plan local en s'adaptant aux conditions
locales et surtout de faire de la
pédagogie sur cette réglementation
je constate une chose partout les
associations de handicapés qu'ils
dialoguent avec la commune et bien la
ville est devenue accueillante la ville
et l'habitat sont accueillants aux
indiennes les gadgets comme cet
élévateur rendre service mais ils valent
très cher
faciliter la vie des handicapés c'est
parfois ça il suffit de ne pas être
étourdis vous êtes handicapé
non mais pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
écouté parce que j'en ai des minutes et
s'il y avait un handicapé qui me garer
la mort
enquête réalisée en collaboration avec
olivier harland conseiller d'antenne 2
en matière d' aide aux handicapés le
sport maintenant et le ski tout d'abord
chez les hommes à kitzbühel en autriche
victoire dans le slalom de l'allemand
bitzner chez les femmes à grindelwald en
suisse énième triomphe pour la suissesse
vernis schnyder patrick naf breni
schnyder aux portes de la légende à
grindelwald elle remporte sa neuvième
victoire consécutive
incroyable et n'occupait que la 8e place
à l'issue de la première manche à 36
centièmes du meilleur temps celui de
patricia chauvet un retard qu'elle a
réussi à rattraper sans le moindre
problème et sans effort apparent comme
s'il n'y avait pas d'enjeu à croire que
rien ne peut arrêter son incroyable
série de victoires qui la rapproche du
record historique dannemarie mother
creux déception en revanche pour
patricia chauvet meilleur temps de la
première manche elle a complètement
craqué bloqués dans les portes chauve et
concède plus de deux secondes à schnyder
dans la deuxième manche elle doit se
contenter de la septième place mais
comment en vouloir à vrai ni chez les
gars le vainqueur du slalom n'est pas
alberto tomba meilleur temps de la
première manche mais l'allemand armin
bittner qui réalise un véritable exploit
il a repris lé 73 centièmes à tombe pas
dans la deuxième manche et battre tomba
à kitzbuehl c'est une bonne raison
d'être contents avant les résultats du
tiercé un sujet d'inquiétude pour le
célèbre trotteur français ourasi ses
deux principaux adversaires américains y
ont renoncé au voyage
le cheval français son driver jean rené
gougeon participé cet après midi à une
dernière course d'entraînement avant le
grand prix d'amérique dans quinze jours
course qu'il croyait tous les deux sans
problème c'était sans compter avec sans
l'apparition d'un 3e américain inconnu
en france qui pour sa première sortie à
paris a fait une très très grosse
impression pierrette brès comme à son
habitude ourasi refuse obstinément de
s'échauffer avant la course
jean rené gougeon lui tapoter fès avec
beaucoup de respect car hors asie
susceptible pourrait se braquer
d'ailleurs regardé avec insistance il
tourne la tête vers son driver comme
pour le prévenir
napolitano le crack américain un vrai
pro fessé crottin se soulagent avant
l'effort et chauffe ses muscles et sera
nourrisson rêveur cherche plutôt à
calmer sa fougue
ils se rendent au départ ourasi et
napoletano sont les seuls à rendre 25
mètres pour hors asie c'est la routine
mais pour napoletano tout est nouveau
alors on lui a bouché les oreilles pour
l'isoler du bruit ils découvrent pour la
première fois les élastiques de départ
et la piste difficile de vincennes à
force de vouloir le défendre son driver
ne l'a pas assez maintenue sous pression
alors gardez napoletano rate son départ
prenant 15 mètres de retard sur oasis
qui lui est bien parti mais c'est grâce
à cela que l'on va pouvoir juger de la
classe pure de napolitano
tranquillement ils recollent au peloton
mais va-t-il tenir de 1650 m il ne l'a
jamais fait pourtant dans la ligne d'en
face il est déjà en cinquième position à
l'extérieur
ourasi adl il est en train de dépasser
qui la gd qui mène depuis le départ il
n'amuse pas le terrain le dernier
kilomètre est couvert en huit minutes 15
secondes 8/10 presque un record à
l'entrée de la ligne droite jean rené
gougeon est inquiet regardez bien il se
retourne à plusieurs reprises il sait
que napolitano et dangereux
d'ailleurs il est déjà dans sa roue le
sprint final démarre il ne s'agit pas de
laisser oasis endormir l'américain fait
une pointe de vitesse époustouflante en
levant la troisième place derrière
queila gédé
alors malgré sa victoire facile jean
rené gougeon et soucieux il vient de
comprendre dans le prix d'amérique il
faudra compter avec napoli tan un
adversaire à sa mesure mais redoutable
résultat dans quinze jours donc pour le
grand prix dans le grand prix d'amérique
le tiercé en attendant il se courait cet
après midi à vincennes sur ce même
terrain pour gagner il fallait jouer le
11 de 9 et le 19 un beau tir c'est un
peu plus de 8000 francs
quant aux cartes et pour 6 francs vous
ajoutez le 2 et vous gagnez un beau
carte est également plus de cinquante
trois mille francs avant de nous quitter
en dernière minute voici maintenant la
composition de l'équipe de france de
rugby qui jouera samedi prochain son
premier match du tournoi des cinq
nations à dublin en direct sur antenne 2
bien sûr à toulouse jean-luc i'm alone
man christian carrer les sectionnaire se
sont donc réunis et vous allez nous
donner la composition de l'équipe de
france qui va affronter donc l'irlande
le 21 janvier prochain jeudi prochain et
bien la voici là peut-être un peu
surprendre surtout au niveau des avants
donc numéro un en d'ars numéro 2 maroco
numéro 3 portolan numéro 4 bourrignon
numéro 5 condom mais rossi s'est si lyon
numéro 7 carminati numéro 8
rodrigues numéro 9 et capitaine
berbizier numéro 10 mais neil numéro 11
lagisquet numéro 12 andrieu numéro 13
c'est la numéro 14 bureaux numéro caf
blanco pour les remplaçants dal maso
armary erbani sens charvet cambérabéro
bon alors effectivement on constate un
gros changement surtout devant première
ligne est aussi troisième ligne première
ligne pour quelle raison parce que en
fait beaucoup de joueurs sortent et de
blessures c'était le cas notamment de
d'un trans et d'art marie n'avons pas
voulu prendre le risque avec aussi peu
d'entraînement pour l'un et l'autre tout
au moins de compétition donc que nous
avons fait appel en d'ars qui était un
garçon confirmait maroco qui a eu sa
chance contre l'argentine
malheureusement ces blessés très
rapidement mais nous croyons en lui en
tant que tu à l'honneur dans le nouveau
système établi puis en dernier écart
important aussi que l'on revient et puis
carminati il ya eu dix ont une
en discussion entre carminati avec
chants et nous avons pensé qu'il était
bon que carminati et sa chance dans un
match en irlande qui risque d'être un
petit peu très dur devant et bien voilà
pour une équipe de france un peu new
look
merci jean louis merci messieurs
résultat bien sûr samedi prochain sur le
terrain de dublin voilà ce journal est
terminée tout de suite après vous avez
les prévisions météo josé blanc la
pierre jacques merino vous donnera les
toutes dernières informations aux
alentours de 23 heures 25 demain matin
6h 45 télématin avec notamment les
résultats d'une grande enquête antenne
de magazines de l'étudiant sur le thème
avoir 20 ans en 1989 avec un un sondage
exclusif sur les préoccupations et
souhaits des étudiants et puis à 7h45 l'
invité des 4 vérités sera alain minc
pour parler de l'europe de 1992 13h
william leymergie brigid simmonds étage
n'oublie personne 20h avec l'autre quant
à nous si vous voulez bien on se
retrouve samedi prochain bonsoir bonne
soirée bonne semaine à samedi prochain